You are going to learn about positive
communication skills for leaders. I'm
here with my good friend and co-author
Julian Miralvel and we're going to talk
to you all about some content from our
recent book also called positive
communication for leaders. We wrote this
book and we're making this video series
because now more than ever leaders need
to be able to connect with their
followers, their employees, to build
relationships and help cultivate a team
that's cohesive and effective. In fact,
we're doing a seven-part series. This is
video number one where we're going to
break down all of the behaviors in this
model of positive communication that
Julian came up with several years back
and we've now built a book around it on
leadership and this video series. So,
let's get right into it. Julian, what is
a positive leader? Well, you know,
positive leadership is all about
dreaming about the people who inspire us
and we want people who are watching this
video to feel it, too. So, try to do
this exercise with us. Think about one
of the most inspirational leaders that
you have worked with in your own
professional career.
Try to identify someone specific.
Somebody who made a real positive
difference in the workplace for you.
What was it like to work for them? What
emotions did they bring out of you?
And what did they specifically do to
make you feel this way? What if you
aspect of the leadership that really
encouraged excellence in you but maybe
also other people around you? And if you
can think of specific habits, maybe
personality traits, but more importantly
core behaviors, what they did, then
perhaps you can identify what we're
going to be describing in these seven
videos. And we'd actually like you to
pause the video right now if you don't
have someone specific in mind. It's
really important that you think of a
specific inspirational leader who you've
worked directly with in the past in one
way or another. The goal, of course, is
not to just talk about this
inspirational leader in your life but to
help you become one, too. We don't know
what you wrote down. We don't know who
you're thinking about. We don't know
maybe you don't even know that person.
But we believe that there are some
elements of inspirational leadership
that transcends all leaders who are
doing this way and all cultures. You
know, we've tested this now, this
question, in the United States and
Canada but also in Saudi Arabia and
Costa Rica and number of other cultures.
And we found that no matter where we go,
inspirational leaders have common
qualities, no matter where we live and
work.
So, often those individuals are leaders
who make us feel valued and they make us
feel respected.
These leaders are people who create an
environment where we feel like we can
thrive, where we're really empowered.
And obviously, they create a great place
to work, an environment that's
challenging but that's also encouraging
and safe for all. In short, they are
what Alex and I would call a positive
leader. They make choices every day
about how to be and how to act and those
actions end up creating an extraordinary
workplace. And what we want to show you
is how you can do that, too. So, what
Julian and I are doing in this series is
we're looking at six key communication
behaviors for leaders and we're going to
make a follow-up video for each of those
six behaviors where we drill down
deeply. Right now, we're going to give
you an overview of these six behaviors
so you get an overview of the overall
positive communication model that Julian
created. And Julian's going to start us
off.
The first behavior of positive
communication is greeting.
Greet to create human contact. The act
of greeting, we know, acknowledges that
other people exist and it naturally
moves us in the direction of others. And
so, as a leader, Alex and I really
encourage great leaders to create lots
of connections with people and learn how
to repair relationships when they're not
doing well. When you choose to greet
other people, you also choose to create
great connections and build
relationships.
The second behavior is asking questions.
Ask questions to discover the unknown.
The questions you ask shape the
responses you get in conversations with
other people. And as a leader, you need
to place yourself in a position of
discovery so that you can learn about
your followers' needs and interests and
wants and their world so that you as a
leader can adapt and enter their world
more successfully. You can lead
essentially through asking better
questions. That's a real concept that is
hard to understand because most leaders
want to talk at their people and there's
a time and a place for that, but we want
to coach you to learn how to ask
questions to develop relationships and
get to know people better. Third,
positive leaders give compliments. They
use positive communication to affect
others. Complimenting others affects
their sense of self. We believe that
what you say and do shapes not just who
you are and who other people are, but
also fundamentally shape who they
become. And so, as a leader, you can use
the power of communication to affect
others in a positive direction. And the
behavior we want people thinking about
is complimenting and the ability to give
specific, meaningful feedback to build
people up and strengthen the people you
work with along the way.
Fourth is disclosure. Disclose more to
deepen your relationships. Now,
disclosure happens anytime you reveal
anything about yourself to other people.
As a leader, that means talking about
who you are, maybe even outside of work
a little bit. It's about revealing your
opinions, stories about your background.
It's about telling people your
expectations so they don't have to read
your mind. It's about sharing gratitude
and expressing that gratitude because
people may not realize how grateful you
are for them. Now, when you disclose, it
can feel a little vulnerable and when we
get into the specific video about
disclosure, we'll address that. But
anytime you are disclosing and putting
yourself out there, you're starting to
strengthen the relationships that you've
begun forming earlier. The fifth
behavior of positive communication is
encouraging.
Encourage your people to give support.
Every workplace is going to face
challenges. Every employee will have
moments of great times but moment of
really difficult time. And what great
leadership is all about is finding ways
of supporting the people around you to
succeed. Leadership is both managing
crisis but also finding ways to motivate
and encourage the employees at the right
moment and at the right time. When you
choose to communicate effectively, what
you're doing is you're using
communication as a gift and then you
have the ability to provide the support
that people need to succeed and we'll
show you how.
The sixth part of this model is
listening. Improve how you listen to
transcend differences. Now, no
comprehensive model would be complete
without listening. On a personal level,
you need to practice what we call deep
listening to your followers and your
employees so you can understand their
needs. Those Those followers need to be
heard and you as a leader have that
responsibility. That means, of course,
removing distractions and really 100%
being all in, focused on your listening.
When you listen deeply like that, you
will transcend the perceived differences
between you and others and between and
among your followers and that will help
create more team unity and bring people
together to create cohesiveness in your
organization's culture. You find common
ground and you begin to understand how
you can work together.
Those are the six behaviors. That's an
overview. Taken together, these six
behaviors form the model or the wheel of
positive communication for leaders. And
as we asked earlier, how many of these
behaviors did that inspirational leader
that you thought of do? If you think
about how they come across, how they
communicate with you and other people
around them, we're wondering how many of
the six they do. It shows you how
important these are. And over the next
several weeks, as I mentioned, we're
going to be putting out six more videos,
one on each of these six behaviors that
are going to drill down more deeply and
coach you through exactly how to do
them, when to do them, even give you
some good starter sentences and samples
so you can see exactly how you can apply
them. We're also putting out a free
email class, a mini email class, a
series of nine emails that echo what
you're going to be learning in this
video series. And of course, you can
find our book on Amazon, Positive
Communication for Leaders. We'll put
links to all of that in the expandable
description below the video. We'd love
to hear how you would answer the
question we posed at the opening of the
video.
Who is the most inspirational leader who
has affected you? Can you please put
that in the comments section? What
emotions did they bring out of you? What
did they specifically do to make you
feel that way? And what aspect of their
leadership style encouraged excellence
in you?
Leadership is about influencing others.
And what we're really going to show you
is how to use the power of positive
communication to inspire others
effectively. Leaders like you can be
powerful role models to motivate others.
Be sure you tune in for the next video
where we're going to show you how to do
greetings much more effectively and show
you how powerful that can be in starting
conversations and starting
relationships. Thanks for tuning in. We
look forward to reading your comments
below. Until next time, God bless. See
you soon.
You are going to learn how to greet
people effectively in conversations.
Good greetings are the fundamental
opening of every social and even
professional conversation. Our focus is
going to be on professional settings,
but you can use good greetings in any
interaction in your life. And I'm here
with Dr. Julian Mirivel. We co-authored
a book together called Positive
Communication for Leaders. It's built
around a six-part model that Julian
created years ago, and it's the backbone
of this video series and our book. In
fact, this is video number two in a
series of seven videos that we're
putting out over the next several weeks.
We hope you stick around for all of it.
Today, we're focusing on greeting people
with intention and all the power that
comes from opening conversations on the
right foot like that. So, first, why are
intentional greetings so important? So,
Alex, greetings are important because at
the heart of human connection.
Interactions that start with simple
things like good morning, it's good to
see you, or even and how are you matters
more in the world of leadership than we
think.
When you greet other people, you
literally acknowledge their existence. A
greeting says, "I see you. I know that
you're there." And more importantly, it
cues to the other person, "I want to
connect with you." It's me moving in the
direction of others.
So, while greeting is a small behavior,
we know that it can have an outsized big
impact.
Because the ultimate goal of positive
communication is to create high-quality
connections, a word developed by Jane
Dutton, a professor emerita at the
business school at the University of
Michigan. And these are short, positive
interactions that have a range of
beneficial outcomes for both people and
their cultures. Greeting is moving in
the direction of other people and making
it possible to start those high-quality
connections. Now, if you think greetings
are too easy, too simple to study and
practice, I'd like to say more about how
a good greeting is much more than simply
saying hello. A greeting serves a number
of functions, especially in a
professional setting. So, greetings open
up a sequence of communication between
two people. Someone has to make the
first move. you've ever been sitting
there in a room where people haven't
greeted each other and got to know each
other, it can be very difficult to feel
comfortable around them because they're
unfamiliar. But a greeting starts the
communication sequence. Greetings also
both define and affirm people and
relationships.
Moving in to say hello, when you do
that, you're demonstrating that you're
open, approachable, you're willing to
engage, that you care about other
people. This is one of the reasons why
when employees at the lower levels of
the pyramid, so to speak, feel so
honored
and cared for when a high-status leader
in the organization actually greets
them, knows their name, says hello.
Because it says to the employee, the
follower, "You matter. I care about you
enough to pause for a minute and greet
you." And greetings also, third, help
you build a bridge to achieve a specific
purpose. So, beyond the social
connections, when you're in the
workplace, you greet someone as just the
beginning, and it's understood that
there's probably some task collaboration
that's going to follow that greeting,
and you can't get to the task until you
have a good opening to the conversation.
So, a greeting just sets the stage. It's
just the beginning. But what happens,
Julian, if we don't greet each other
with intention? Let's look at the other
side of the coin. So, you know, Alex,
when we don't greet each other with
intentionality, first what happens is
the relationship is hurt, right? Without
communication, there is no relationship.
Without greeting, there's no quality
connection.
But if we don't pay attention to these
details, interaction can quickly feel
awkward. I'm sure you've been in a
situation where you say hello to
somebody and the other person doesn't
respond, and suddenly you feel, "Wow,
what's what just took place here? You
know, I feel totally alone and isolated
from this encounter." A second thing
that happens is it feels disrespectful,
right? So, if we're walking down the
hallway and our boss is not even seeing
us, is not even acknowledging us, we
feel disrespected in some form. So,
being attentive to that detail really
matters in the world of leadership. And
then finally, we have not caring.
You know, most of us, we want to be
valued, we want to be loved in some way.
And greeting is the way is a small way
of showing to people, "Hey, I care about
you. I want to see how you're doing."
And when we pay attention to it, we can
start to transform what the
relationship's all about. Greetings help
us connect with each other relationally,
and they create a stage for working
together even more effectively. Now, you
probably know a good greeting when you
see it, but we're going to spell it out
for you so that you can do it more
consistently and reliably. There are
four
elements of a good greeting. Here they
are. First, it has to be authentic. You
have to actually care about other
people. If you just give a default
automatic greeting, they're going to
feel that it doesn't come across as
genuine. So, you have to muster up your
actual care for other people when you
greet them, and then it'll feel more
authentic, and you'll form a little
connection. Second, you have to do
something verbal. You have to say hello,
"Hey, how you doing? Good morning. How
was your weekend?" Verbalize your
greeting. Don't just nod at them. But
third, nonverbal is also important. You
nod, you make eye contact, you pause and
orient your shoulders toward the other
person. And four, be patient. Don't rush
your greeting. You have to take that
extra couple of seconds to greet them
effectively. We believe that greetings
are a literal leadership behavior
because as we wrote in our book,
Positive Communication for Leaders, it's
a leader's responsibility to initiate
connection with their people. The
leader, in other words, sets the tone.
So, Julian, tell us about your example
you were sharing with me the other day.
Well, you know, I just had a a wonderful
visit with a Japanese executive. I was
in Costa Rica, and we just found each
other really at a restaurant, and we
ended up kind of talking and engaging in
conversation. And as I got to know him,
he shared his whole leadership story.
And really, it was one of sadness. He
realized that he was isolated. He
realized that he was not treating his
people particularly well. In fact, he
said, "You know, for most of my career,
when I would go to the office, I would
walk straight through the hallway. I
wouldn't even say hi to people, and I
would go to my desk and straight to my
PC."
And even when people went to see him in
his office, he'd be working away, typing
at the computer. If somebody would come,
and he would say, "Okay, thank you."
Barely make eye contact and barely
engage. And he said, "As a result of
that approach, he lost a lot of respect.
He lost a sense of connection to people.
And it had consequences. And he said,
"Now, I'm having a paradigm shift. I
realize I cannot just be a boss talking
to objects. I have to be a leader from
person to person."
And he started to implement some of what
we're describing, which is moving
towards others and asking how they're
doing and checking in with colleagues.
And when people come into the office,
then you respond positively to the first
part of the greeting. And he noticed
that those relationships started to
grow, and not only that, but his
leadership approach grew as a result,
and his influence, of course.
Wonderful. So, here is your challenge,
your application for this video, anybody
watching, so you can get on the right
path.
First, make a list of two people in your
organization that either don't know, but
you want to, or that you know you need
to connect with more.
Next, give each person a call or a quick
visit in person. You can do this on
email if you must, but we really think
face-to-face or a phone call is the best
way to start forming a real connection.
Next, give them your best greeting and
simply tell them that you wanted to
check in and see how they were doing.
Next, make a little bit of small talk,
and then see where the interaction takes
you. And at the end of the conversation,
there may be a need to follow up, and
you can make a plan to follow up later.
That's your challenge for this video.
Start greeting people well. Do it with
intention, and start with two people who
you can identify specifically. So, this
is the second video in a series of seven
videos on positive communication for
leaders. We invite you to watch all
seven videos. We're going to put links
to all of them once they're all posted
in the description below, along with a
free email class series that you can
sign up for that mirrors or echoes and
reinforces what we're talking about in
the videos. And of course, you can pick
up a copy of the book on Amazon if you'd
like. Links to all of that is in the
description below the video. So, we'll
see you in the next video, where we're
going to talk about the importance of
asking questions, a critical leadership
behavior. We look forward to reading
your comments in the comment section
below. Until next time, thanks. God
bless, and we will see you soon.
Today, you're going to learn how to ask
better questions in conversations. And
I'm here with my good friend Dr. Julian
Mirivel. We recently wrote a book
together called Positive Communication
for Leaders. It's built around a
six-part model that Julian created years
ago, and we recently wrote this book
about it, and we're also doing a video
series around it. This is video number
three in a seven-part series on each of
the individual behaviors in that model.
And we're going to get right to it today
about how to ask good questions.
So, your first step as a leader is to
commit to asking more questions. Julian,
why should we ask more questions?
Well, you know, for leaders, asking
questions is so important. It
immediately puts you in a position of
discovery.
And as leaders, we just tend to get into
the habit of just telling people what to
do. We give lots of directives, and we
acknowledge that there's a time and a
place for sharing information in that
way. But what makes questions so
powerful and so much more effective is
that they engage people,
and they get the leaders to be placed in
a position of discovery. And as a a
questions immediately accomplish that
goal and help you really lead to
concrete positive outcomes.
Here's some facts that Alex and I really
like. You know, one of them is this,
only 6%
of all acts of communication are
actually questions.
But 60%
of what we say is actually in response
to a question. In other words, questions
are exponentially more engaging than
just making statements. And research
shows that once we ask a question, our
minds almost entirely focus on trying to
answer it. So, what makes questions
powerful, Alex, is that when you ask a
question, you set in motion what the
next turn of talk is going to be about,
what other people are going to say, and
that's going to shape what the
interaction is all about.
Good questions will give followers and
colleagues an opportunity to voice their
opinions, but it's also going to show
them that you care about their views and
about them as people.
Asking questions is a fundamental
leadership behavior. In fact, there are
lots of benefits to asking questions
versus simply making statements. In
fact, the benefits are really hard to
believe. So, simply by asking more
questions, here's what you benefit from.
Individuals who ask questions and listen
deeply are more likely to be perceived
as leaders.
Leaders who ask meaningful questions for
input are seen by others as increasing
effectiveness.
Leaders who ask meaningful and
respectful questions create more
encouraging work relationships, and
leaders who ask good questions
successfully motivate their employees.
So, given all of these benefits, we're
asking you start asking more questions
in the next 24 hours after watching this
video. And the more questions you ask,
the more repetitions you'll get, and you
will get better at this the more you do
it. So, the second tip, in addition to
asking more questions, is to improve the
quality of the questions you ask.
Julian, how can we do that? How can we
ask better questions?
So, what we show in the book and what we
really want you to learn in today's
video is how to flip your questions, to
move from asking close-ended questions
to asking open-ended questions. And
there's a big difference. Open-ended
questions typically start with words
like how,
what, or why.
Close-ended questions tend to start with
words like, are you, will you, did you?
And you'll notice that close-ended
questions control and narrow the
interaction versus open-ended questions,
which kind of give it an expensiveness,
right? A breadth of answers. Let me give
you a scenario. So, you come to work on
a Monday morning, you go see a
colleague, and you ask, did you have a
fun this weekend? And the person may
say, yeah, how about you?
And you notice that's a close-ended
question, did you have fun this weekend?
And the answer you got is very short. In
fact, you've learned nothing about your
colleague, what they enjoy doing, or
even about their weekends.
Close-ended questions can be acceptable
as a starting point, but you notice that
for leaders, they need to learn to ask
open-ended questions cuz that's where
the connection is, and that's where you
can learn from other people. So, take
the same situation. It's a Monday
morning, you go to work to see a
colleague. What if instead of asking,
did you have a fun weekend, you flip the
question and just ask, what did you do
this weekend?
And you'll notice the person may respond
with something like this, oh, I did all
sorts of things, you know, I went to the
beach on Saturday with my family, then
on Sunday we cooked a great meal
together, and they may share even more
information. And the more they share,
the more you'll learn, and the more
you'll learn, the more you'll have
understanding. And that's what you want
as a leader.
Open-ended questions virtually always
lead to a more robust conversation than
close-ended questions. So, here are some
sample open-ended questions that you can
ask your followers. Here are the
questions you might ask to discover what
your followers think. For example, what
is your opinion on this? How do you feel
about X?
What do you see as the next steps? Here
are some other samples you can ask your
followers if you want to discover more
about them outside of their role at
work. You could ask, tell me your story.
What are some of your personal and
professional goals? Who are your role
models?
When do you feel truly energized and
engaged at work? I recently asked one of
these questions when I was out to dinner
with Julian.
We were both presenting to a client in
another city, and the client took us out
to dinner the night before our
presentation. And after we ordered our
food, we had some time to talk, and I
simply asked each of our hosts, tell me
your story.
And they said, well, what do you mean?
What story? And I said, your whole life
story.
And for the next 45 minutes to an hour,
the four of us went around and basically
told our life story, short versions of
our life story. In fact, one of the
people went back about 400 years to when
their where their ancestors first
arrived in the United States. And you
could feel as the conversation went on,
we were discovering the unknown about
each other, and our relationship was
deepening with each talking turn. It was
really a fantastic conversation, and the
person the next day mentioned what a
powerful interaction it was. So, Julian,
why don't you tell us about the next
steps for this video? Yeah, we'd like
you to take a few next steps. And the
first one is, if you have used a great
open-ended questions that has worked for
you, put it in the comments below so we
can all learn from each other and have
lots of examples of great open-ended
questions to open up our conversations
with others.
But the second thing we would like you
to do as a next step is to commit to
asking more questions, better questions,
and more open questions in the next 24
hours. We want you to feel and see the
difference if you move from asking
close-ended questions to asking
open-ended questions in your
interactions.
So, specifically what we'd like you to
do is go meet with a follower or a
colleague or an employee and ask them
three meaningful open-ended questions to
position yourself in a mode of
discovery. Make this whole intention
about getting to know them and getting
to understand their perspective and
their worldview. And you'll notice that
when you do that, something really
magical happens in the interaction. As
we say in our book, it's up to leaders
to position themselves to ask better
questions and to discover what people
have to say. And when you do that,
you're going to experience something
completely different in the realm of
your relationships, both even at work
and at home. This is the third video in
this series of seven
for communication for positive leaders.
We encourage you to stick with the
entire series. We're going to post all
of the videos once they're all posted
out there in the expandable description
below the video. You can also sign up
for the free mini email class that
mirrors what we're going through in
these videos. And of course, you can
pick up a copy of our new book at
Amazon. Links to all of that are in the
description below. We look forward to
reading your comments. And in the next
video, we're going to work on how to
give compliments, another key behavior
for positive leaders. We'll see you
then. Bye-bye.
Today, you're going to learn how to give
positive feedback, specifically how to
give genuine compliments. This works in
a workplace situation, but works really
in any kind of relationship. And we are
in video number four in a seven-part
series. I'm here with my good friend Dr.
Julian Muraville. We co-wrote a book
together called positive communication
for leaders, and this video series is
based upon that book, which is based
upon a model of positive communication
that Julian developed several years
back. In part, leadership is about
creating an environment in which people
feel valued, respected, and engaged. And
one of the best ways to create that is
by giving more positive feedback. Our
approach in this video is to show you
how to give genuine compliments to build
relationships and enhance employee and
organizational performance.
Complimenting is one of the six key
behaviors in Julian's positive model of
communication.
In the model of positive communication,
we argue that complimenting
affects people's sense of self. It
affects not just who they are in the
moment, their identity, but it more
importantly impacts who they're going to
become. Complimenting is a powerful form
of giving positive feedback because one,
it's the most direct way of telling
another person who they are and how we
see them.
It also identifies specifically good
performance or great performance. And
then, it shapes the other person, their
sense of self, their identities.
Positive feedback, complimenting, and
recognition drive toward lots of
benefits for leaders, many of which we
mentioned in the book. Consider several
facts from the most up-to-date research
we have on this topic. The most
compelling driver of an employee's
performance is the quality of the
relationship that they have with their
immediate supervisor.
Focusing on strength is going to improve
performance, whereas focusing on
weaknesses, which is going to undermine
performance. And then finally, employees
consider recognition for a job well
done, respectful treatment, and coaching
and feedback more important than pay
across the board.
Let's make this even more personal right
now. Take a moment to reflect on your
experience as an employee, some kind of
follower, when you've been in that role.
What is one compliment you've received
in your professional career that has
meant a great deal to you?
Who gave you this compliment, and how
did it affect you in the short term and
the long term? And you may even want to
take a moment to write down exactly what
was said so you can see the words, see
the message. You may notice that as you
remember this and write it down and
bring it to mind right now, it can start
to create some of the positive feelings
that you felt at the time.
Let's give you our own illustration.
Here's a compliment that I received that
made a very positive impact on me and my
professional development. Years ago,
when I was a young professor at the
university, on a Friday afternoon around
4:00, I received a phone call.
I picked up the phone and I said, "Hi,
this is Julian Mareveal. How can I help
you?"
On the other hand was David Belcher, who
was at the time the provost of the
university, the chief academic officer,
and he's giving me a call.
He says, "You know, Julian, I'm about to
become chancellor and I'm moving and
transitioning to a new university, but I
wanted to make a few phone calls to
people I really believe in on campus.
And I want you to know that you're an
extraordinary teacher, an extraordinary
scholar, and you're going to be an
amazing leader for this institution.
I can not wait to see what you're going
to do in the next 10 years." That
compliment really impacted me, not just
in that moment, but for years to come.
You can see how a sincere compliment
from David Belcher influenced Julian. He
remembers it to this day. It wasn't just
shaping how he felt in the moment, it
shaped how he saw himself moving forward
in the future. And in the same way, now
imagine the kind of impact you can have
by giving sincere compliments to the
followers and employees who you work
with. The bottom line of this video is
we want you to start giving more
compliments to the people around you.
Look for ways to reach out and give them
some positive feedback like that. So,
what can you give compliments about?
Let's get it even more hands-on for you
right now. Start by focusing on two key
areas where people generally want to
feel those compliments come their way.
The first is that we all have a need to
be seen by others as competent. The
second is we need to feel appreciated,
liked, and valued. So, those are two
areas that you can give other people
compliments. So, right now think of an
actual person in your professional life.
Reflect on when you have seen them at
their best in terms of what they might
be demonstrating their competence for.
So, maybe you saw them, for example,
doing a great presentation. Perhaps you
saw them handle a difficult situation
well during a meeting. Now, in the same
way, think about a compliment that you
may communicate to them that shows that
you like them and appreciate them. Now,
keep in mind, you have to give
appropriate compliments. This is a
workplace setting after all. We don't
recommend, for example, you give other
people compliments about their
appearance. That can often come off the
wrong way.
But you can give them compliments about
how you feel about them in terms of you
appreciate them and you like them. For
example, Julian just the other day sent
me a text about how much he enjoys
working on this video series together
and on our book together that we
collaborated on for a couple years. He's
really good at that. So, the key to
these compliments is being sincere. This
can't be calculated like you're doing it
to get something from them. Genuine
compliments are the most direct way to
give positive feedback to people and
shape how they see themselves.
Let's take some action today.
Step one. Take a minute to identify one
person you work with that could really
benefit from a compliment. This person
could be a peer, a supervisor, or simply
a subordinate, somebody who you work
with every day. Step two. Consider these
questions to draft your very own
meaningful compliment. When have you
seen this person at their best? When
have you recently seen this person do
something special or even make an
important contribution? And more
importantly, you can ask, "What strength
do you see in them on a consistent
basis?" Once you've answered these
questions, you move on to step three.
You craft your compliment. When drafting
your compliment, make sure to identify a
specific example of when you saw the
person do something great and explain
how what they did has led to positive
outcome on the basis of their strength.
Let me share with you a compliment I've
been drafting for Alex, who's really
been influential in our ability to write
the book, but also make great progress
in our own personal and professional
lives. Working with you, Alex, is an
absolute highlight of my career.
You're kind, you're generous, you're
ethical, and you're so energizing in
everything that you do. I'm inspired by
what you are doing and who you are as a
person and a professional every day. And
more importantly, you've helped to make
the book that we wrote together concrete
and practical. And you always kept
refining it until it was something that
we were both really proud of. In short,
I'm thankful for our friendship and I'm
thankful for your leadership.
Thanks, my friend.
Thank you. I don't want to pause for too
long here cuz we're in the middle of a
video, but I really appreciate that,
Julian. So, once you've crafted your
compliment, you have to move to step
four because we have to let people know
how we feel and that's step four. Step
four is deliver your compliment.
Research shows that the most meaningful
way of delivering a compliment is to do
it in person because it's the most
memorable. If you cannot do that, if
that's not possible, feel free to
express your compliment maybe in a
personal written note. Either way, and
as we explained in the book, the most
important part of complimenting is
communicating it.
Now, the reason we're emphasizing that
last point is because here's an
interesting fact. Professionals often
don't compliment their people even when
they think positively about them. And
they don't do it for three reasons. The
first reason is they think positive
thoughts, but don't bother to say them
out loud. Second reason is they expect
that the interaction will be awkward
when they express it. And the third is
they simply don't think that it's
important enough to acknowledge others
aloud. In other words, you personally
may have to push yourself to compliment
others. In a study, only 50% of the
participants who actually prepared a
written compliment followed through and
delivered it. And we hope that you are
in that 50%. So, we're encouraging you
to actually deliver the compliment and
begin to give more compliments as a
result of watching this video. People
don't have access merely to what you
think and how you feel. They can't see
that. They only have access to what you
actually do and actually say aloud. And
that's why communicating the compliment
is so important. So, make sure you're in
that top 50% who communicate it. As a
leader,
you need to use every opportunity you
have to strengthen the people you work
with, to build them up and prepare them
for their future.
And we hope that using what you're
learning in this video, you can apply
this principle and seize those
opportunities at every moment. This is
the fourth video in a series of seven
that we're making that break down all of
these skills in the book on positive
communication for leaders that you can
check out on Amazon. Also, there's a
free 9-day mini email class that you can
sign up for. We'll put links to that.
And please feel free to leave comments
below. We look forward to reading them.
In the next video, we go into the topic
of self-disclosure for leaders in the
workplace, which is a really challenging
one. We hope you tune in for that. Until
then, thanks. God bless. We'll see you
soon.
Today, you're going to learn how to be
more open in the workplace through
self-disclosure.
Now, the focus here in the video is
about professional settings, but
self-disclosure can help deepen any
relationship. And I'm here with my good
friend and co-author, Dr. Julian
Mareveal.
Julian and I wrote a book together
called Positive Communication for
Leaders. It's the foundation of this
video series. We're in video number five
of seven videos. Self-disclosure is one
of the key six communication behaviors
in our book, and it's a really important
tool that should be in every leader's
toolbox. We'll put a link to the book in
the description below, as well as a link
to the mini email class that you can
sign up for. In our experience,
self-disclosure is the behavior in the
positive communication model with which
most people are least comfortable. In
the model of positive communication,
we propose that when leaders choose to
disclose, they naturally deepen the
relationships that they have with other
people. We know today that 52% of CEOs
feel lonely in their roles. We know from
reports across the world now that people
feel generally lonely in the workplace.
Approximately one in four adults does
so. And leadership positions in general
within organizations often do not foster
the kind of work environments where
friendship and social intimacy are
possible.
And the only way out of that loneliness
is to learn to use the power of positive
communication to connect more deeply
with people. And disclosure is the
secret sauce for that goal. It's an
important leadership behavior because
disclosure deepens your relationships
and your connections with other people.
So, first, let's talk about what
disclosure is and is not. At a basic
level, disclosure is about revealing
aspects about yourself, information
about yourself, that people would not
know unless you told them. Just the
other day, for example, a colleague of
mine shared some of her long-term
professional goals with me that I would
not have known unless she talked about
them. In the same way, even in
professional settings, disclosure can
mean telling people about what you did
over the weekend, talking about your
family if you're comfortable with that,
or sharing a bit about your hobbies and
interests outside of work. Disclosure
really is about an endless list of
potential activities or information that
you might share that show who you are,
show how you think, how you feel, and
let other people get to know you.
Ideally, for relationships to be
deepened, disclosure needs to include
certain key features.
It must be authentic and genuine. It has
to be truthful and honest. And it needs
to be spontaneous rather than strategic
or calculated. And more importantly, it
has to be personal. When we disclose
with these features, we get to know each
other as whole human beings, find common
ground, and learn to trust each other.
So, here's what disclosure is not. In
contrast to that list of positives,
disclosure is not about airing all of
your dirty laundry, or getting too
personal too fast, or telling other
people information that's really not
suitable for the workplace.
Additionally, we'd like to be clear here
that disclosure is not a superficial
tactic that you use to get something
from somebody, or to close a sale.
You're not relating to people in that
strategic way. We assume that you
genuinely value people and have their
best interests in mind when you're
disclosing. And naturally, you must use
your best judgment anytime you're
disclosing and adapt any advice we're
giving you to your situation and your
personality. Second, let's talk about
how you can begin disclosing in helpful
ways at work. The easiest way to get
started is to learn to tell your story.
Here are a couple ways. One is to share
information about your own personal and
professional journey. In most
situations, the leader in the room has
been through similar experiences in the
past. And telling others about the ups
and downs of our experiences and your
experiences can be a great way to bond
with other people. We know this may seem
straightforward, but the question is,
are you doing it yet? After this video,
we hope you do, because sharing your
story has lots and lots of benefits for
connection.
For example, in healthcare settings,
research has shown that doctors who
reveal their own experiences to patients
improve not only patient satisfaction,
but their adherence to treatment and the
likelihood that they would pursue legal
action in a bad scenario. In the realm
of education, we know that teachers who
share their experiences with students,
whether that's their academic hardships
or even stories about their lives, not
only impact student satisfaction, but it
literally improves student learning.
Sharing your story is at the heart of
how to create more trust and better
working relationships with people. And
if sharing your story makes you a little
bit anxious, remember that you are the
decider. You can decide what to share
and what not to share, and you can
always use your best judgment. Now,
here's our pro tip on that topic.
Disclose a little bit and see how it
goes. Test this out. So, you reveal a
little bit of personal information and
see how the other person responds. If it
goes well, then you reveal a little bit
more over time and at your own level of
comfort. So, here's another way to
self-disclose. You can share some of
your foibles, and I'll explain what that
means in a moment. So, this is going to
take a little courage. We're not used to
talking about our weaknesses, but
consider disclosing some of your small
shortcomings or small weaknesses. People
can really relate to this. In our book,
we draw on the writings of Allan Wiener.
He's a fellow speaker, author, and
consultant, and he makes a habit out of
talking about his small weaknesses or
foibles with his employees, but even
really high-level executive clients that
he works with in Fortune 500 companies.
A foible is a small weakness. When I
talk about mine, people talk about
theirs. Sometimes that helps us make a
connection. I think I've surprised a lot
of people by my willingness to share a
weakness, and it's helped them open up
to me. The more unsuitable my weakness
to a point, the more I have invited such
a connection. And most of the time, the
person I've been talking with about my
weakness will say, "Don't be so hard on
yourself. I can get you one better."
Drawing on this example, we know that
talking about our small weaknesses can
humanize you, and it's going to make you
more approachable as a leader. It opens
up the door for others to do the same,
because it liberates other people to
hear you speak genuinely about yourself.
And third, expect other people to
reciprocate. The most likely result of
your self-disclosure is that other
people will do the same. In the field of
communication, we call this reciprocity.
When you share information about
yourself, the most likely result is
people will start to disclose a similar
type of information from their own
lives. In our presentations, we talk
about this as a magic wand. Disclosure
is the closest thing we have to a magic
wand in terms of a concept in
communication. When you disclose, other
people almost automatically reciprocate,
and you've probably felt this dynamic in
conversations with other people.
And it creates a real bonding
experience. You can feel the
relationship develop. It's almost like
giving each other small holiday exchange
gifts. You can feel your relationship
bond over those disclosures and those
gifts. And in fact, one of the ways we
do this in our live presentations is we
talk about ourselves a lot to help us
get to know the audience and vice versa,
but one of the ways we do it is to show
pictures of my two dogs. That's
something for my personal life. It has
nothing to do with work, and I put them
up on the screen, and I tell a quick
story about them, and we now stop our
presentations and give everybody there
the opportunity to share pictures of
their dogs as well, because when I
self-disclose, like a magic wand, they
want to reciprocate and share about
their own pets, and they do that with
the people around them. And it's so
effective at getting people to bond and
converse that we actually have to
put a stop to it after a couple of
minutes. The bottom line is this,
disclosure deepens relationships and
connections with others, and that's why
we consider it one of the most important
positive communication behaviors. Your
next steps are simple. In the next 24
hours, apply these steps. Use any
opportunity you have to tell more of
your personal or professional story
whenever it fits the situation. If
you're feeling courageous, share a
foible, a small weakness, so that people
can connect with the real you. And more
importantly, if you hear someone
disclose, remember that that's the magic
of disclosure, that you can reciprocate
and share your very own story.
This is video number five in this series
of seven videos on positive
communication for leaders. We invite you
to sign up for the free 9-day mini email
class that echoes everything in here.
And when these are all done, we're going
to post them in links in the description
below the video. And of course, you can
always check out our book on Amazon. So,
we'll see you in the next video, where
we're going to talk about the importance
of encouraging other people when they
face difficult situations. We look
forward to reading all your comments
below. Until next time, thanks. God
bless. We'll see you soon.
Encouraging your people is part of your
leadership responsibilities. And oh boy,
do we need encouragement today. And
you're going to learn how to do that in
this video. I'm here with my good
friend, Dr. Julian Mirevel. We
co-authored a book together called
Positive Communication for Leaders.
That's the basis of this video series
we're doing. In fact, this is video
number six in a seven-part series that
follows along with the book. If you'd
like to, you can check out that book on
Amazon, and you can also check out our
9-day mini email class that follows and
reinforces what we're talking about in
these videos. And today's topic is
encouragement. Encouragement is a key
leadership behavior in the model of
communication that Julian developed
years back. And today, you're going to
learn how to create extraordinary
moments with your people through the
power of encouragement. People need
their leaders to encourage them now more
than ever. In the wheel of positive
communication, we describe the power of
encouragement as the ability to give
people the support they need to succeed.
When we encourage, we give social
support. Consider some statistics that
we bring out in the book. For example,
according to a recent article by Jason
Kenuf and his research team, employees'
grief costs US businesses about $75
billion annually. And job stress and
burnout have been estimated to cost the
industry hundreds of billions of
dollars. Similarly, we know today that
employees feel very lonely. In fact, a
recent poll revealed that eight out of
10 employees, that's 82%, say that they
feel lonely in the workplace.
Now, on the flip side, we know that a
little compassion goes a long way. For
example, when leaders demonstrate a
preference for compassion, their
followers are 25% more engaged in their
jobs, 20% more committed, and at an 11%
lower risk of burnout. Leaders who show
compassion also personally benefit, as
they experience a 30% increase in their
own sense of well-being and happiness in
their lives. In other words, your
encouragement, your compassion, your
support make a measurable difference in
everybody's lives. In short, all
employees and followers need to feel
that they're cared for. They need to
feel attended to, but they also need to
be reminded of why we do the things we
do.
So, how can you as a leader supply the
power of positive communication to
support your employees and transform
ordinary moments into what Alex and I
see as extraordinary ones? And the short
answer is this. Take every opportunity
you have to encourage your employees
with any of these easy and practical
three strategies, plus a bonus one that
we're going to share after those. The
first one is this. Give sincere and
meaningful advice to support your
employees in one-on-one moments. I had a
great boss once who years ago was having
lunch with me to mentor me.
And for a long time I was a smoker, and
in that conversation gave me some advice
that stuck with me. He said, "You know,
Julian, how you quit smoking, don't
you?" And I said, "No, what are you
talking about?" And he said, "If you
really want to quit smoking, you have to
learn to quit one cigarette at a time."
And it took a while for this
encouragement and advice to sink in. But
about 2 weeks later, I decided to quit
smoking, and I've been smoke-free now
for over 16 years. One piece of advice
made a huge difference and encouraged me
to do what I wanted to do to begin with.
And it certainly remains a memorable
moment, as you can see, because Julian
told me about it years ago and reminded
me of it as we were writing this book.
The second strategy is to alleviate
distress by providing support. So, I
used to be the chair of my academic
department. I teach college full-time
still, and for about 4 years, I was the
chair or supervisor of my department. I
was really burned out at the end of that
time. But my new chair, my new
supervisor, was amazing at providing
support. He sensed that I was burned
out. He gave me an amazing teaching
schedule, really ideal, so that I would
have a little more free time. And he
also delegated some of the heavy
responsibilities that I had been
carrying to other people to rotate that
so that other people could handle them
to alleviate my distress. And fast
forward to this year, I feel refreshed
and I'm having my best teaching year
I've had in a long time. And he did this
by providing support. He alleviated my
distress, and that was an incredibly
supportive, very practical way that he
helped me.
The third strategy is to help your
employees refocus on their strength
after they have failed or after they've
encountered a setback. For the book that
we wrote, Alex and I interviewed a
professional who told us a story about a
time where she had made a big mistake at
work. So, the first thing she did is she
called her boss and admitted to all the
things that had happened as a result of
some of the actions that she took. Her
boss on the phone, after listening to
all of her concerns and solving the
problems, then told her this. She said,
"Annelise, you're really good at what
you do. You're good at your job, and you
care, and you can overcome any
challenge, no problem." That
encouragement made a huge world of
difference in Annelise and helped her
overcome the failure that she had just
encountered. These are all small but
thoughtful behaviors that you can do to
take difficult moments and turn them
into fond and extraordinary memories,
just like the memories that we have. So,
fourth, your bonus strategy is the
encouraging power of your presence.
Simply being available, simply being
present and giving another person your
time is sometimes all that's needed, and
it may in fact be all that you can do.
Not every difficulty or discouragement
that someone's going through can be
something that you can fix and do
something about on a practical level.
However, you can make a difference just
by being there to offer your time,
attention, and support. Sometimes that's
the biggest difference that you can
make, simply to make yourself available
and let them know that you are there for
them. Let's get practical. Here's your
challenge for this video. Identify one
employee or a colleague who seems to be
a little disconnected from work, maybe
even disengaged from the mission. Reach
out to them personally and make some
time to interact one-on-one. Third step,
make sure to ask lots of questions about
their experiences at work and to listen
as deeply as you can to what they're
going through. When it's appropriate,
then use that time to offer one
meaningful advice or meaningful, fitting
piece of encouragement.
And remember, sometimes just your
supportive and encouraging presence will
be the very best thing that you can
offer someone during times of
difficulty. Those are the kinds of
memories that they may carry with them
for a long time. This is the sixth of
seven videos in this series on positive
communication for leaders. As I
mentioned, you can sign up for the 9-day
free mini email class that echoes the
contents and reinforces everything we've
been talking about, and you can always
check out our book on Amazon. We'll see
you in the next video, the final video
in this series, on the importance of
deep listening for leaders. We look
forward to seeing you there and looking
at your comments in that section below
the video. Until then, see you soon and
God bless.
Listening skills are a critical skill
for every leader, and you're going to
learn how to improve your listening
skills today. I'm here with my good
friend and co-author, Dr. Julian
Mireville. We wrote a book called
Positive Communication for Leaders that
this video series is based upon. In
fact, this is the seventh and final
video in this series. You can go back
and watch the rest of the videos. We'll
put links to the entire series in the
description below the video. And if
you'd like to sign up for the free mini
email class that echoes everything we're
talking about in this series, you can do
that as well. And by the way, I just
want to take a moment here at the end of
this series. If our names sound
familiar, you may recognize us from our
blockbuster movie series Madagascar. I
am Alex the lion, of course, he is the
original King Julian. Now, we're just
joking, of course, but our names really
are
very similar, and we've had those names
before those characters, and I actually
do call Julian the original King Julian
for fun once in a while, and I've been
called many times Alex the lion. Anyway,
back to our story. We're going to talk
about listening. It's a key leadership
behavior, and Julian's going to talk
about this skill from the perspective of
his model that he created on positive
communication. When you choose to listen
as a leader, you're choosing to
transcend the perceived differences that
exist between you and other people. Why
is listening such an important
leadership behavior, Alex? Well,
listening is an often overlooked and
usually undervalued communication skill.
It often doesn't look like anything's
happening, but if you want to take your
leadership seriously, then you have to
work on your listening. Because the
higher up leaders go in any
organization, the more time they spend
listening. In fact, as we show in our
book, executives spend twice as much
time listening compared to the average
employee, and emerging leaders spend
more and more time listening as they
move up the ladder in any kind of
organization. And people in all walks of
life, whether they're in an organization
or in their personal life, love great
listeners.
But there are real, important, practical
benefits to being a great listener.
Leaders who listen well and deeply get
to know their people better. They also
can be more easily identifying the
emerging problems that are taking place
on the ground. They have more input
about solutions that could be more
effective to solve real problems. They
also are really good, if you use
listening, you can resolve the problems
before they get bigger. And more
importantly, most of us, we want to
avoid hard conversations, right?
Difficult moments. If you can listen a
little bit more deeply, you can avoid
these hard talks because you're managing
problems all along the way. For these
reasons, it doesn't surprise us that
some of the best listeners we've ever
met are leaders sitting at the top of
the organizational chart. So, what does
good listening look like, sound like,
and feel like? Well, in our book, we use
the term deep listening to indicate that
listening well goes beyond superficial
tactics like fake listening to give
people the impression that you're
listening when you're not. For example,
deep listeners follow three key
behaviors. First, deep listeners are
fully present and completely in the
moment. Deep listeners put their phones
away, they reduce all distractions, they
literally lean their bodies in, and they
listen with their eyes, not just their
ears. Deep listeners, for example, are
never looking over your shoulder to see
who else might be a little more
interesting in the room. And a fully
present listener makes you feel like
you're the most important person in the
world at that moment. They are fully
present, and that is a choice. For
example, they say that Elvis Presley
made you feel like you were the only
person that existed in the entire
universe while he was speaking to you.
He made you feel special. And if the
king of rock and roll had the time to
make people feel that way, so can you.
Deep listeners are also open. You know,
openness is about welcoming new ideas,
perspectives, and approaches. We know
that remaining open is difficult, but it
does not mean abandoning your point of
view. In fact, openness is all about
maintaining a really fine, delicate
balance between holding on to your own
perspective and being profoundly open to
the perspective of others. Openness is
typically difficult for people to
develop because it involves our ability
to accept and welcome new information,
which may even contradict our own
thinking. We interviewed a variety of
leaders for the book that Alex and I
wrote, but one of them said this.
Leaders in general are very stubborn.
They believe in something and they keep
on pushing, whether people agree or
disagree.
But he added this important piece of
information. He said, "But I have found
that listening deeply always gives me a
new perspective."
So, gaining a fresh perspective, even if
one may not fully change their view, is
obviously critical for leaders. So, as a
leader, we encourage you to remain open
to hearing new ideas, to hearing new
thoughts, and constructs that will help
you innovate, adapt, and hopefully
thrive.
The third behavior is that deep
listeners show empathy. Put simply,
empathy is your ability to put yourself
in the other person's shoes, to
understand their world, and to feel what
they are feeling in that moment. Empathy
usually involves pitching back what you
believe you have heard or asking a few
follow-up questions to make sure you are
understanding the other person's point
of view accurately.
So, I'm going to give you a few
straightforward examples of how you
might respond in the moment. We're going
to be really straightforward here. When
good listeners respond, they keep their
responses low-key.
For example, they may say things like,
"I hear you." "Make sense." "I see what
you mean." Or even simply, "Hmm."
You'll notice that these replies are all
very short. Great listeners are not
eager to take their own big talking turn
or to jump in with a story to match your
story. They are entirely focused on
understanding you and understanding your
world. As Stephen Covey might say, great
listeners listen to understand, they
don't listen to simply reply. Let's get
actionable. Here is your challenge. This
is a simple action step, but it takes
commitment and courage on your part to
execute this challenge. In the next 24
hours, strive to make listening your
dominant goal in any conversation that
you're having. It's going to be your
purpose. Use the tips that we've shared
in this video to listen more effectively
and more deeply. Remember that it's a
part of your job. Here's a quick
summary. Recognize that listening is a
leadership responsibility. And deep
listening means that you become fully
present, that you become fully open, and
that you become empathetic. We know that
listening in one-on-one conversations is
foundational. And in our book, we also
explain how you can use the power of
listening to build an extraordinary team
and a great organizational culture heart
and centered on compassion. As
mentioned, this is the seventh of seven
videos in this series on positive
communication for leaders. Feel free to
look at the entire series. We'll put
links to the whole thing in the
description below the video, as well as
links to the book on Amazon and that
free mini email class. And if you've
watched this whole series, I just want
to encourage you to leave a comment
below. Tell us you've watched the entire
series, and I'll be sure to heart your
response and also respond to what you
have written. And I just want to say
thank you for hanging in there with us.
This is Alex the Lion and the original
King Julien signing off for this series.
Until next time, thanks, God bless, and
we will see you soon.